sigue así ese amanecer es la bandera de
esta argelia de argelia que parece
imbatible en áfrica mares es el capitán
de este equipo lleva 26 goles
convertidos en 70 partidos con su
selección y es él quien lidera a un
equipo que también tiene 11 de sus 28
jugadores jugando en las cinco
principales ligas europeas es un equipo
que despliega un fútbol que no no se ve
en en áfrica que incluso cuando no tiene
sus mejores días marca las diferencias y
que tiene en maleza su gran figura pero
también sostenido por varios jugadores
de gran nivel viene de ser el campeón de
la última copa africana de naciones en
2019 tiene un largo invicto que llega a
los 34 partidos y para colmo demostró
que tiene el recambio porque con su
equipo a él con su equipo mejor dicho
ganó la última copa árabe en diciembre
en frente estará sierra leona un equipo
mucho más modesto que regresa al torneo
después de 26 años y qué
y ha incorporado a jugadores nacidos o
fuera del país descendientes de
sierraleoneses para reforzar al equipo
de cara a este torneo parece
insuficiente para hacer frente a argelia
que es el gran favorito del torneo
claramente y que podemos decir desde
otro gran partido ese duelo entre
nigeria y egipto
es un choque de históricos que se va a
llevar a cabo en garúa en egipto es el
equipo más ganador de la historia de la
copa africana de naciones con siete
títulos en nigeria la ha ganado en otras
tres ocasiones y es un equipo que
habitualmente participa de los mundiales
de fútbol 'los faraones' él son
dirigidos por carlos queiróz el ex
seleccionador de colombia que le ha dado
una cierta evolución sobre todo en
cuanto al orden del equipo y que tienen
obviamente la gran esperanza apuesta en
mohamed salah el mejor jugador que llega
aquí a camerún y en un equipo que ha
demostrado solidez porque ha perdido un
solo partido en el 2021 enfrenta esta
nigeria que tiene la historia pero
convive siempre con el caos el
entrenador interino agustín en wabho en
él se hizo cargo del equipo durante el
torneo atrás en la salida de gernot por
hace muy pocos hace un par de semanas y
a la espera de la llegada de jose
peseiro al portugués ex seleccionador de
venezuela que será a cargo de las
superáguilas después del torneo hay
bajas importantes en el equipo verde por
víctor o ciment que no puede participar
debido a una lesión y al hobbit 19 y
también por cuestiones administrativas
quedaron fuera emanuel de odion ighalo
dos de los delanteros importantes que
tiene en nigeria que igualmente
intentará sostenerse en el jugadores
como ahmed musá o que le eché a nacho
para seguir siendo protagonista de
áfrica